Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard einen guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich am
altbewährten Ort am altbewährten Ort du
schreibst du denkst du liest genau ich
schreibe ziemlich viel ja und zwei
Sachen gleichzeitig und ja das verrate
ich noch nicht so ganz aber jetzt im
Augenblick so bei dem schönen Wetter und
in letzter Zeit wenig unterwegs gewesen
das ist das schönste was ich ja dann was
ich überhaupt am liebsten mache in aller
Ruhe an Büchern basteln ich habe mich
dieser Tage mit Ferdinand von Schirach
dem übrigens wieder ein großartiges
kleines Büchlein gelungen ist Regen
quasi ob du schon gelesen hast wegen ein
schönes Buch so über das Leben an sich
und es gibt so es gibt darin so eine
Passage die ich so unfassbar mag erzähle
ich dir gleich aber nur über das
Schreiben der schreibt 20 30 mal bis ihm
dann so ein Absatz wirklich gefällt und
lässt weg und lässt weg und ist weg der
beginnt und morgens und hat eine
bestimmte Zeit und dann hörte einfach
auf und der schreibt weniger zahlen am
Tag Gesetze am Tag ja also es kommt ja
vielleicht auch darauf an was man
schreibt also ich meinen Roman die
Kosmonauten geschrieben habe habe ich
nie mehr als eine halbe Seite am Tag
geschrieben und ich habe aber auch an
jedem Satz immer wieder neu gefeilt und
so weiter und quasi so versucht Lyrik in
Prosa zu machen also jeder Satz musste
in sich geschlossen und perfekt und
sowas sein
und hier bei bei dem Büchern die ich
jetzt schreibe es ist eigentlich ja so
dass man das schreibt und schreibt und
schreibt und schreibt und am Ende kennt
man das noch mal so wie Haare immer
wieder durch und immer wieder durch und
dann macht man das eine noch schöner und
dann schiebt man noch mal Gedanken
dazwischen und so weiter dass das dann
gut klingt aber da halte ich mich
während ich schreibe nicht damit auf
dass ich jetzt sage dieser Satz muss
perfekt sein
ist interessant die Frage stelle ich mir
dann wenn ich im Schloss Lektorat bin ja
er hat jeder so ganz unterschiedliche
Arten zu arbeiten ich finde nur das was
dabei herauskommt wenn Menschen wie du
oder auch verdienen von shirach der
wirklich weltweit erfolgreich ist wenn
die mal wirklich sich in sich versenken
und anfangen nachzudenken das ist
wirklich großartig in diesem neuen Buch
Regen ne ja sagt er unter anderem ganz
zum Schluss die meisten Menschen wollen
etwas sein was sie nicht sind ja und
sagt dann ich habe mir meinem Leben viel
falsch gemacht das ist die Schuld von
der in diesem ein Stück das wird auch
ein Theaterstück die Rede ist ja die
eigene Schuld verjährt nicht damit musst
du leben oder auch nicht aber sagt ich
habe da noch etwas anderes verstanden
und den Gedanken fand ich so schön die
Raumsonde Voyager one ja startete 1977
von Cape canaberal das war die erste
Sonde die unser Sonnensystem jemals
verlassen hat und obwohl sie eigentlich
keine Kraft mehr hatte schickte diese
Sonde 1990 letzte Fotos zu Erde und zwar
über eine Strecke von sechs oder sieben
Milliarden Kilometer das ist die größte
Entfernung aus der jemals ein Foto
gemacht wurde und auf einem dieser Fotos
sagt Schirach ist unser Sonnensystem zu
erkennen viele Sterne und links unten
ein winziger hellblauer Punkt das ist
die Erde dort ist alles was wir waren
und alles was wir sind und wenn du
dieses Foto ansiehst dann wird Dir klar
wie verrückt wir sind dass wir Kriege
führen und uns gegenseitig töten es gibt
100 Milliarden Sonnensysteme und im
Weltall 200 Milliarden solcher Galaxien
das alles zusammen sind etwa 10% des
Universums der Rest ist leer und Minus
270 Grad kalt wir sind einsam und nicht
scheint ein Sinn zu ergeben aber wie
alle sind es und deshalb ist es diese
Einsamkeit die uns verbindet nach dem
Theaterbesuch treten sie auf die Straße
sie sehen die Menschen die beleuchteten
Cafés die Restaurants und plötzlich wird
dir bewusst dass uns das gehört dieser
Moment diese Farben die ganze wunderbare
Vielfalt des Lebens in einem einzigen
Augenblick und das ist dann wenn Sie so
wollen Glück
ja und und wenn man jetzt irgendjemand
hat den man es vererbt entweder weil man
es nicht vererben will oder weil man es
nicht färben kann oder über die
Nachkommen sich gar nicht darüber freuen
was man ihm für ein Quatsch vererbelt
dann merkt man das Bedeutung eigentlich
immer ein Gegenwart gebunden ist ne die
Bedeutung die wir den Dingen bei Messen
der hat überhaupt gar keine Relevanz für
die Ewigkeit genau aber beide sitzt
denken wir das immer so na das ist so
für immer und für ewig und das ist jetzt
meins so das gehört mir und das nimmt
mir keiner Weg spätestens der Tod nimmt
uns die Dinge weg richtig und und es ist
sozusagen dieser augenblicksgedanke der
mich daran so fasziniert ich habe mich
dieser Tage mit meinem Sohn darüber
ausgetauscht und er sagte zu mir weißt
du eigentlich wie alt der Stegosaurus
ist du kennst ihn natürlich als
chronologisch
Zeit ja der mit diesem Rücken Platte auf
Augen ja uralt also unvorstellbar Kinder
ja das ist also jura-zeitung 100
Millionen Jahre her genau und da gibt's
Forschung dazu sagte er und dass der der
so unfassbar alt ist der Matte zu mir
Papa überleg dir mal der Tyrannosaurus
ja der Rex der ist
erdgeschichtlich betrachtet näher am
iPhone als am Stegosaurus stimmt das
stimmt Jura zu dem ist ja noch länger
der Kreidezeit ist ja so vor 65
Millionen Jahren ja stimmt dann ist Jura
Zeit noch ein ganzes Stück länger
herunter 140 Millionen oder so ja aber
dann wird mal so die Dimension klar ne
ja wenn man sich überlegt erfolgreich in
den Dinosaurier waren ja wir machen uns
ja gerne darüber lustig dass die dummen
waren ne also ich weiß schon als ich als
Kind mich für Saurier interessiert hat
gab es so Beschreibung ja das ist Gehirn
des Triceratops nicht größer ist als
eine Apfelsine genau
so groß war doppelt bis dreimal so groß
wie Nashorn ja mit seinen großen
Panzerplatten da und seinen spitzen
Hörnern aber dahinter eben total dumm
richtig so und in Wahrheit hat es viel
längeren auf der Erde gegeben zum
Beispiel Menschen ja und das jenes Tier
das ich am meisten seine Intelligenz
berühmt das ist was in kürzester Zeit
den größtmöglichen Schaden auf der Erde
angerichtet hat und wahrscheinlich bald
wieder verschwindet spricht ja nicht
wirklich für seine Intelligenz so und da
sind wir direkt beim Thema sie wollte
mit dir heute genau darüber mal reden
Intelligenz gibt nämlich ein tolles
neues Buch von James riddle die
unfassbare Vielfalt Designs Jenseits
menschlicher Intelligenz das ist
sozusagen der Untertitel und die Frage
ja ob wir nicht Intelligenz eigentlich
komplett neu bewerten und ganz ganz neu
definieren müssen finde ich super
findest du super spricht mir absolut das
Herz ja also
du hast doch immer diese schöne
Formulierung ne das haben schon ein paar
mal drüber gesprochen also dein Zitat ja
von Pia sie von Pia ja dass ich immer
sage Intelligenz ist das was man
einsetzt wenn man nicht weiß was man tun
soll genau und ich habe darauf dann
zugedichtet Kreativität ist das was man
einsetzt wenn man nicht weiß was dabei
rauskommt richtig das ist also sozusagen
die Ergänzung zur Intelligenz aber
dieses schöne Gedanke Intelligenz ist
das was man einsetzt wenn man nicht weiß
was man tun soll genau das ist doch
wunderbar das ist wunderbar und das und
das Spannende ist ja immer dass wir
Intelligenz ein menschlichem Maßstab
bemessen ich habe ja mein erstes Buch
also mein erstes Sachbuch über das
Verhältnis von Mensch und Tiere
geschrieben und da war das das was mich
am meisten eigentlich fasziniert hat als
jemand der ja immer von Tieren so
fasziniert war wie viele verschiedene
Formen von Intelligenz es gibt wie viele
verschiedene Formen von Sensibilität es
gibt die mit dieser Intelligenz
zusammenhängt die wir überhaupt nicht
wahrnehmen wir schicken ja wenn wir
immer rauskriegen wollen wie Tiere sind
die immer so ein völlig unfaires
olympisches rennen wir nehmen immer die
Disziplinen indem wir gut sind und
Messen alle anderen da dran ja also wenn
es eigentlich Tiere gibt die quasi gut
für Kugelstoßen sind dann schicken wir
die auf 100 m Lauf
also wir finden es solche dumm an Tieren
dass sie im Laufe der Evolution die
menschliche Sprache nicht gebraucht
haben ja aber wir haben die ja nur
deswegen weil die für uns nützlich war
und für viele andere Tiere unter Wasser
zum Beispiel wer die überhaupt nicht
Bedeutung gewesen ja genau so das ist
also merkwürdig ist wie einseitig ne wir
immer Intelligenz betrachten und
besonders beschäftigt habe ich mich
wieder ineinander mit als ich über
künstliche Intelligenz nachgedacht ja
weil ich immer denke wir gehen jetzt in
so ein Zeitalter ein wo wir mit Hilfe
der künstlichen Intelligenz eine noch
mal ganz ganz andere Welt schaffen ja
und je mehr wir über diese künstliche
Intelligenz lernen die wir da selber
erschaffen umso mehr lernen wir das ganz
anders ist als die menschliche
Intelligenz und das unsere menschliche
Intelligenz durchsetzt ist mit Emotionen
und dass sie auch nur von diesen
Emotionen ja überhaupt ihren Sinn und
ihre Bedeutung gewinnt aber das ist ja
im Tierreich dasselbe ja das heißt also
unsere Physiologie aus der unserer Wille
kommt unsere Gefühle die tief in unsere
Physiologie sind die alle bestimmen
unser Denken und meine Formulierung ist
das im Zeitalter künstlicher Intelligenz
das nicht so ist dass die Tiere und die
Pflanzen wie ganz sagte dass andere der
Vernunft sind sondern heute gehen wir in
eine Zeit ein in der Menschen Tiere und
Pflanzen das andere der künstlichen
Intelligenz sind das heißt wir rücken
wieder an die Pflanzen und die Tiere
zusammen und der Graben besteht zwischen
Mensch und künstlicher Intelligenz und
nicht zwischen Mensch auf der einen
Seite und hier und Pflanzen auf der
anderen Seite
er ist interessant ich meine Brille ist
ja da auch sehr hart er sagt eine
Intelligenz die den Planeten und die
Menschheit zu vernichten droht
ist die intelligent Fragezeichen ja da
stehen wir wieder vor dem großen Problem
dass wir ja keine verbindlichen
Definition von intelligent haben aber
wir können uns zumindestens darauf
einigen Weise ist das nicht und
vernünftig ist das auch nicht
ja beschreibt unter anderem ein einen
einen Vogel im Norden von mosambikias
als als Beleg dafür sozusagen dass auch
Tiere und Pflanzen Fähigkeiten haben die
sehr sehr intelligent sind ja gibt es
einen Vogel der mit den Menschen quasi
kooperiert Honig Anzeiger erkennst du
den hast du mal gehört von diesem Vogel
der Sucht Bienenstöcke im Wald Switcher
den Menschen zu und führt sie dann quasi
zu diesem Fundort und dann Räuchern die
Menschen diese Bienenstöcke aus und
teilen sich anschließend sozusagen den
Honig mit dem Vogel als belegt für eine
besonders schlaue Kooperation das zweite
ist die die Geschichte kannte ich ja die
schlaue Krake Otto erinnerst Du nicht
daran sondern eine eine Krake die ich
nicht aber Kraken sind ja wie du weißt
wenn meine Lieblingstiere
unglaublich unglaublich das ist der
Mensch des Meeres ne obwohl ich jetzt
wieder den Fehler mache und den Mensch
zum Maßstab zu machen aber sagen wir mal
das ist auf seine Art und Weise verfügen
Kraken über eine neuronale Komplexität
die ist wahrscheinlich mit dem Menschen
aufnehmen kann
im Bereich der Menschen maßlos überlegen
ist und vor allen Dingen die Kranken
machen sollen wirklich sehr weisen
Umgang mit ihrer Intelligenz verbringen
ja ein sehr erheblichen Teil ihres
leider sehr kurzen Lebens mit Sex
ja und sind die Weltmeister die
Weltmeister der Erotik weil
Krankenversicherung krankenverfügen aber
mehrere Herzen ja und bei mehrere
Gehirne und krankenverfügung der
selbstverständlich natürlich auch über
drei Penisse also die Männchen die
Weibchen über drei Klitoris ja und davon
werden auch jeweils immer nur einer für
die Fortpflanzung eingesetzt und der
Rest war Spaß genau und weil sie also
diese diese diese großartige Ausstattung
haben machen sie einen unglaublichen
Gebrauch davon also Liebesspiel und die
rote konzentriert sich über Wochen und
so weiterhin und das ist natürlich ein
bisschen weiser als materielle Güter
anzuhäufen und die Welt zu zerstören
oder sich gegenseitig zu erschießen sie
ist deutlich schlauer ja also wie die
Kranken bringen sich nicht untereinander
um ihre Auto ne war ein kraketen im
Coburg in Franken in so einem großen
Aquarium und der hat damals die
Aufmerksamkeit von Medien erregt weil er
achtung beim Jonglieren mit
einsiedlerkreb erwischt wurde ja sehr
schöne Geschichte ja oder ein anderes
Mal hat er irgendwie Steine gegen die
Seitenwand seines Beckens geworfen und
ab und zu mal dann sozusagen den Inhalt
dieses gesamten Beckens einfach neu
geordnet um es nach seinem Geschmack zu
gestalten ja
die die aufräumen das ist tatsächlich so
ja interessant ne dass wir die eine der
Fähigkeiten die der die der Mensch mit
Kraken teilt ist dass er seine Behausung
aufräumt ein Bedürfnis hat danach ja
woher kommt das was denkst du ist es ist
ist es sozusagen also mich stresst es
wenn die Bude aussieht wie verrückt der
denn dann krieg ich im Kopf Stress
deswegen
ja nicht
in der Pubertät ist das sehr selten da
hat man meistens Bedürfnis nach
aufräumen und sie gar nicht
aber es ist doch kann ja auch sagen es
ist schon Zeichen Mangel da Intelligenz
dass man sich also nur in geordneten
Umgebungen zurechtfinden findet
damit man weiß wo die Dinge sind oder
dass man nicht irritiert ist oder
überfordert bin ich bin noch nicht ganz
sicher dass Menschen die besonders viel
aufräumen dadurch offenbaren dass die
besonders schlau ist der Krake Otto in
Coburg der steckte hinter einem
Kurzschluss als alle Lichter regelmäßig
ausging in diesem Aquarium und da gab es
eine Katzen Kurzschluss in diesem
Aquarium der dafür sorgte dass die
anderen Tiere die da waren plötzlich
bedroht waren das Leben dieser Tiere
weil die Filterpumpen ausgefallen sind
und dass das dann zum dritten Mal
passiert in nachts haben sich
Mitarbeiter da mal hingelegt haben auf
dem Boden geschlafen um die Ursache zu
finden und dann gemerkt dass Otto sich
auf den Rand des Becken schwingt und
Wasser auf diese tief hängende Glühbirne
spritzt weil sie nervt und hat damit
sozusagen diesen Kurzschluss ausgelöst
bzw herausgefunden wie man es nicht
ausschaltet ja also das spricht sehr für
ein intelligentes Wesen das offenbar
nicht nur mit Sex beschäftigt ist
ja das ist ja kein Widerspruch also das
klingt ja fast so als wenn die viel mit
Sex beschäftigt werden irgendwie genuin
dümmer sondern ich finde das ist eine
der besten Möglichkeiten des Intelligenz
gebrauchts also darf dafür spricht das
nicht ein Kraken sind irre also wenn man
sich überlegt dass die über hunderte bis
in die Tausende von farbindungs
miteinander kommunizieren die machen ja
unausgesetzt das was wir mit Worten
machen machen die mit Farben ja die
können also Zuneigung ausdrücken indem
sie sich farblich wieder andere färben
ja also bis ein besseres ich verstehe
dich oder ich versetze mich in dich
hinein gibt's ja gar nicht wie Empathie
durch durch Angleichung von Farben
herstellen oder Männchen wenn sie
miteinander rivalisieren bringen es dann
auch schon mal fertig sich im Weibchen
zu verwandeln rein farblich
oder sich wie Weibchen zu verhalten ja
das war bis zur Unkenntlichkeit
also dass das sind wir also solche irren
verhaltensrepertoas wie der Mensch sie
also nur in ganz zarten Ansätzen
überhaupt hat es gibt nur eine riesige
Tragik die über dem Kraken Leben lebt
dass der Krake vielleicht nicht
empfindet aber die ich empfinde sie
werden nicht alt wie alt werden so zwei
oder zweieinhalb Jahre ist gar nicht
eindeutig ja das ist vielleicht ist das
der Grund Energie haben keine kulturelle
Evolution
sie haben keine lange Zeit ihren Kindern
viel beizubringen
nicht gut das ist ja ganz große Vorteil
in der Menschheit der der Krankheit
eindeutig die besseren Anlagen als der
Mensch so dolle ist das nicht auf dem
Bäumen rum zu hüpfen und ein bisschen
mehr nach vorne sehen können als der
Seite sehen können so dass alles also im
Grunde genommen von der Ausstattung her
übertreiben wir ja immer dass wir sagen
was wir für für für Meisterwerke in der
Schule funktioniert die menschliche Hand
was die alles kann und was weiß ich was
können die von 400 anderen privaten
Arten auch ja und mit der Hand sind
viele andere Tiere sehr geschickt der
Krake hatte die mit Abstand besten
Voraussetzungen aber was soll man tun
wenn er wie alle genießt ja frühstückt
er kann da nicht nicht viel weiter
tragen und kulturell überliefern weil du
gerade Farben sagst Richard ich ich
musste eine Geschichte erzählen 2014 da
waren wir noch etwas andere Sendung der
hatten wir den britischen Autor Daniel
zu Gast
hatte Bücher geschrieben die
millionenfach übersetzt worden sind und
so weiter millionenfache auflagenähnlich
erfolgreich wie du und Therme ist Autist
im Grunde sozusagen Rainman ja wenn du
so willst lass den Hoffmann in Rain Man
und der kann sich die Kreiszahl Pi ja
bis auf
22.500 irgendwas Stellen hinter Komma
merken und aufziehen
Mathematik ist für ihn bunt und fröhlich
ich weiß noch der hat mir das damals
auch so beschrieben für ihn sind das
Farben deswegen kam ich gerade drauf für
ihn sind das Farben für ihn ist das
Poesie für ihn ist das ja für ihn ist
das sozusagen alle eine wunderbare
Beschäftigung ein wunderbares versenken
irgendwas dieser Mann kann schneller
rechnen als du überhaupt in der Lage
bist die Zahlen in einen Rechner
einzugeben ja und hat mir damals die
Ehre Geschichte erzählt der Wein eine
isländische Fernsehsendung eingeladen
und war dann so fasziniert von Island
hat sich eine Woche Zeit genommen und
einen Coach und nach einer Woche hat der
Fliesen Isländisch gesprochen das wäre
hochbegabt ja also auf dem Spektrum ganz
weit draußen und auch der sogenannten
im Fachvokabular genannt also die
Wissenden
war das war jemand Mensch der mit
unseren sozusagen mit diesem normalen
spießermaßstäben wie ich ja ich ich kam
damit nicht klar es du merkst sofort
alles was der sozusagen an sozialen
Fähigkeiten hat wenn er lächelt wenn er
sich nach vorne beugt wenn er mit dem
Kopf nicht wenn er dir Aufmerksamkeit
schenkt wenn er mit der Mimik versucht
dir sozusagen Zustimmung zu vermitteln
oder was auch immer das war und das war
es war ein völlig irritierender und
irgendwie auch befremdlicher Moment das
war alles andere trainiert der kann das
nicht von Haus aus der ist nicht dazu in
der Lage in irgendeiner Form Gefühle zu
kommunizieren und alles was da kam das
hat er auch so erzählt war alles
antrainiert er sagte ich ich weiß du
erwartest jetzt dass ich Freund Lächeln
dann tue ich das auch ich weiß dass ich
jetzt
sozialer wünscht die haben mit dem Kopf
nicken soll und dann mache ich das jetzt
auch aber mir ist nicht danach und das
ist nichts was einfach so spontan aus
mir herauskommt dass das fand ich
wahnsinnig fasziniert und dachte was
muss das auch für einen für ein Leben
sein hat dann auch davon berichtet kann
man auch in seinen Büchern lesen ist das
älteste von neuen Kindern glaube ich
älteste von 9 und sein Vater war ein
englischer
industriefabrikarbeiter der den
überhaupt nicht verstanden hat dann
arbeitslos wurde der große Tragik und
ihn dann noch schlecht behandelt hat
aber seine Mutter seine Mutter hat ihn
heiß und ich geliebt und die war
sozusagen die war der der Humus der
fruchtbare Boden auf dem dieses Genie
dieses Kindes dann doch wieder ein
konnte und er erzählte mir in der Schule
geschlagen wurde gehänselt wurde weil er
halt eben nicht zu dieser sozialen
Interaktion fähig war und wie dann seine
acht Geschwister in dieser Schule um ihn
her quasi so ein ein Kokon gebaut haben
die haben immer so ein bisschen auf
ihren großen Bruder aufgepasst weil sie
gemerkt haben der tut sich da wahnsinnig
schwer und das hat mich damals sehr
berührt weil ich dachte was ist das
eigentlich für ein Leben dass solche
Menschen leben die an ihrem Genie auch
verzweifeln können ja das sollte man mal
all den Eltern sagen die der Überzeugung
sind dass ihre Kinder hochbegabt sind
ja so eine erschreckende Tendenz unserer
Zeit das ist nur noch hochbegabte Kinder
gibt davon ja viele leider
sich der Eltern versteckt hochbegabt
versteckt hochbegabt oder nicht genug
gefördert oder von den Lehrer nicht
erkannt und so weiter aber die die die
die wichtige Pointe daran ist eine
richtige höchstbegabung ist eine Strafe
ja genau
NICHTS aufbaut wozu ist die Steine nicht
woanders her holt und das große
Geheimnis hinter den Macht zu sein macht
richtig einsam
bist bist du in anderen Bereichen nicht
so schlau
genau der kann ich Auto fahren der kann
sich keine Gesichter merken es kann der
alles nicht ja genau also ich bin kein
Autist und ich kann auch kein Auto
fahren und ich tue mich schon mit
Gesichter merken schwer und das einfach
nicht weil ich irgendwo irgendwelche
super Begabungen verfüge sondern einfach
weil ich auch ein bisschen einseitig
gezüchtetes Gehirn habe wofür ich
wahrscheinlich selbst verantwortlich bin
das heißt also wenn du in bestimmten
Bereichen unglaublich versuchst was
aufzubauen dann geht das sehr leicht auf
an die Kosten eben andere Gehirn
logischerweise ohne das ist so bei den
savons passiert nun folgendes da sind
Gehirnregionen die für diese Aufgaben
eigentlich nicht zuständig sind in
Anspruch genommen genau also jemand der
wahnsinnig gut rechnen kann der rechnet
gar nicht genau so neuronal mit dem
gleichen Material wir werden normaler
Mensch
verrechnen da sind die diese Funktionen
übernommen haben und plötzlich
Höchstleistung generieren
und das gleiche gilt ja auch für diese
anderen savon-leistungen ich meine wir
hätten mal über Steven wildshire
gesprochen das ist dieser farbige in Los
Angeles ich meine er lebt in Los Angeles
oder er ist über Los Angeles jedenfalls
mal geflogen und dann hat er sich dann
eine Stunde aus dem Hubschrauber glaube
ich raus die Stadt angeguckt und hat
dann auf einer sieben Meter großen
Leinwand oder Papier die Stadt
gezeichnet aus der Luft anschließend und
zwar jeden Baum ja und jedes Fenster in
jedem Hochhaus und jedes schockwerke
geholt alles also das ist ein ganz ganz
Überflug es ist wahnsinnig faszinierend
was aber rausgekommen ist aber der kann
im normalen Leben nur mit einer ganz
ganz tiefschwarz getöteten Sonnenbrille
rumlaufen ja weil er sonst so
reizüberflutet ist dass dieses Gehirn er
heißt dreht das heißt er kann also der
muss seine optische Reize auf ein
Minimum reduzieren
oder es gab einen anderen servus der
ganze Bücher auswendig konnte der auch
meine Zeit lang sehr berühmt war und als
Vorbild von Rainman damals auch geil und
der war aber nicht in der Lage sich ein
Spiegelei zu machen und konnte auch
nicht alleine leben ohne dass sie
irgendjemand bei meinem Alltag geholfen
hat das mit dem Spiegeleis die Form von
Hochbegabungen die er mit vielen anderen
Männern teilt muss man sagen ja das
stimmt natürlich also aber dann kann man
sagen wenn man nicht kochen kann
natürlich
mich hat damals diese Geschichte
wirklich sehr berührt weil ich dachte
wow was ist das was ist das für ein
Leben was ist das für eine Art die Welt
zu sehen und
gleichzeitig sozusagen Bewunderung zu
erfahren und tiefste Ablehnung ja das
was der erfahren hat und irgendwie zu
versuchen sich in unserer Welt zu Recht
zu finden in der man ja auch diese
sozialen Fähigkeiten
unabdingbar braucht und fühlt dann auch
direkt zur Frage was ist eigentlich
Intelligenz ich hatte ich meine wir sind
ja fast nie von von der Frage wie
intelligent ist jemand anders deswegen
haben wir ja irgendwann mal versucht das
zu messen und zu sagen ich weiß es gab
Experimente da wurden die Schädel von
Probanden vermessen um irgendwie
angefangen also also ich bin ja kein
großer Freund von Intelligenztests also
angefangen hat das Ganze also es fängt
ein ursprünglich eigentlich an dem 17
Jahrhundert
ich interessiere mich sehr für dieses
Thema ich habe eine große Sammlung von
historischen Büchern die sich genau mit
diesem Thema beschäftigen also Bücher
aus der damaligen Zeit und da gab es
einen Mann namens kurdo de la schaumreha
der hat also schon versucht irgendwie
kann man an irgendwelchen äußeren
Kennzeichen des Menschen seine
Intelligenz festmachen und dann war
Physiologie so großes Thema Lavater ja
aus Zürich der also auch Bücher
geschrieben hat das wo er eben versucht
hat zu erklären man kann eben ein
äußeren Merkmalen innere Seelen Zustände
in irgendeiner Form ablesen unter
anderem in 1 und dann wurde es richtig
hardcore so um das Jahr 1800 machte ein
österreichischer Arzt eine Tournee
Josef Gall heißt der Mann Josef Gall
Joseph Gall und das war damals ein Thema
das kannst du dir gar nicht vorstellen
das war der der Aufreger schlechthin ja
der zeigte dann Bilder von Schädeln und
zeigt auch Totenschädel und so weiter
und erklärte dass man an der Schädelform
die Intelligenz ablesen könnte das Ganze
grandioskopie also schädellehre oder
frenologie
und das war damals so es war total
verboten ja weil die katholische Kirche
von dort alles nicht gut weil alles das
mit Schädeln und Anatomie und dem lieben
Gott ins Handwerk pfuschen und so hinter
die geheimen Codes zu kommen die Gott
irgendwie ja das war ein großes
Politikum aber das hat ja so den Ruf ja
von verzauberei ja jetzt öffnet sich der
Sesam zur menschlichen Psyche und wer
die Grammatik der Schädelform ja richtig
kennt der weiß immer bei seinem
Gegenüber an dem er ist nein niedrige
stirnverbrecher ja vorgeschobenes Kind
Brutalität und so weiter und das hatte
einen solchen Zauber und das ganz viele
Leute die nur da gewesen waren und sich
nur den Vortrag angehört haben
anschließend Bücher geschrieben haben so
kleine Büchlein ja weil sie meinten das
muss unbedingt unter die Leute gebracht
werden das ist sozusagen der der Code
den der entziffern müssen ihre und das
hat so viel ausgelöst dass dann also
ernsthaftere Wissenschaftler sich diesem
Thema angenommen haben
und vielleicht nicht Frankreich also
jahrzehntelang wurde diese frenologie
dann noch weiter betrieben im
deutschsprachigen Raum ist das
irgendwann der Verruf gekommen aber da
die die die Wissenschaftler haben da
ewig dran gearbeitet lange bevor man
wirklich was von menschlichen Gehirn
verstanden und je mehr man dann
irgendwann vom Gehirn verstanden
je mehr man dann von Gehirn verstanden
ich muss gerade also auf andere Art und
Weise dann noch mal vollkommen
missbraucht von den von den Nazis und
von den
nationalsozialistenlehre die hat das
alles wieder aufgewärmt ne genau und es
gibt in dem Film Django Unchained da
gibt es Leonardo DiCaprio oder der der
da versucht irgendwie die
unterliegenheit der schwarzen Rasse
anhand irgendeine kleinen Merkmals im
Gehirn da irgendwie klar zu machen und
Lauterach auf den Schädel da so eine
ganz erschreckende ja das bezieht sich
auf diese kranioskopischen Forschung ja
ja die die Geschichte muss gerade an die
Geschichte von Sully Perel denken sali
parell war ein ist leider verstorben
mittlerweile den irgendwann vor ein paar
Jahren eine Dokumentation mit ihm
gedreht sullivar lebt den in Tel Aviv
ist dann Alter von 95 jetzt kürzlich
erst verstorben hatte bis zum Schluss
Kontakt mit ihm wahnsinnig netter Mann
der eine Ehre Lebensgeschichte hatte
haben wir glaube ich schon mal drüber
gesprochen und der das Vorbild war für
Hitlerjunge Salomon und es gibt in
seinem Leben und dann auch in diesem
Film eine Situation also der durch durch
durch diverse Umstände Gerät der
sozusagen in die in die Hände der
Wehrmacht wird dann dort gefördert er er
behält dieses Geheimnis für sich dass er
ein kleiner jüdischer Junge ist der der
das darf niemals jemand erfahren und
wird dann geschickt auf die ss-schule in
Braunschweig wir waren dort und haben
dort mit ihm gedreht und dieses Gespräch
werde ich nie mehr vergessen weil er
sagte wir hatten regelmäßig Rassenkunde
und eines schönen Tages sagte der Lehrer
heute zeige ich euch mal woran man einen
Juden erkennt und ruft ausgerechnet sah
die Perlen nach vorne und der erstarrt
und sagt um Gottes Willen jetzt wird er
rausfinden dass ich gar keinen Aria bin
so wie der sich das da vorne vorstellt
sondern dass ich Jude bin und ruft ihn
nach vorne der fängt an diesen Schädel
von von von Sally zu vermessen dass
damals auch gezeigt und beschrieben sagt
um die stand da wie versteinert und
dachte okay gleich gleich gleich kommt
raus aber nichts kam raus sondern dieser
dieser komische Rassenkunde Lehrer sagt
man genau so muss ein reinrassiger Ariel
aussehen wie der Schädel hier von sein
ein völlig ihre Geschichte und er hat ja
Gänsehaut und erzählte wie er den nach
dem Krieg in Hannover waren ja dann
trafen sich ja Millionen von von
Vertriebenen auf diesem Hauptbahnhof in
diesem in diesen in diesen diesen Mitten
dieser Verwüstungen trifft er quasi noch
in den Rauchen in Ruinen in diesen
Lehrer Bahnsteig und geht zu dem hin und
sagt übrigens wollt ihr nur sagen sie
haben sich völlig vertan ich heiße in
Wahrheit sali Perel und ich bin ein
kleiner jüdischer Junge und er meinte
das war irre den zu sehen wie der in
diesem ganzen Chaos und das
tausendjährige Reich am Boden und zu
Ende und alles vorbei und die Ideologie
Tod und dieser Mann wurde blass und
stand dann da drei Minuten und hat kein
Wort mehr gesagt und hat sich dann bei
ihm entschuldigt weil er unglaubliche
Geschichte aber so sozusagen missbraucht
aber nochmal zurück zum Thema Richard
Intelligenz ist ja sozusagen eine der
großen Fragen immer auch von von von
Biologen und intelligenzforschern
Psychologen Psychiatern Neurologen die
Frage was bestimmt eigentlich wie
intelligent jemand ist ist das nur eine
Frage der Gene
oder ist das eine Frage der Umwelt der
Einflüsse in den du lebst ja
ich liebe ja diese Trennung nicht ja
also bei den Zeiten der Epigenetik diese
Trennung sei ihre starre verloren hat
also es können ja wenn es das sicherlich
in erblicher Faktor drin aber dieser
erblicher Faktor ist ja auch wieder
durch das Leben und die Umstände der
vererbenden bestimmt wichtig also auch
die sind ja nicht frei von
Umwelteinflüssen wir wissen dass ich
Lernerfahrung nicht unmittelbar also
nicht auf der Ebene der Gene direkt
vererben aber eben auf der Ebene der
Schalter die für das Aktivieren oder
nicht aktivieren von jedem zuständig
sind also in der Epigenetik und deswegen
würde ich diese diese knallharte
Trennung die man bis vor wenigen
Jahrzehnten Jahr gemacht hat ja entweder
alles ist genetisch das heißt die
terminiert und verrückt war fest da kann
sich nichts dran ändern oder alles ist
Umwelteinfluss ja dass man ja zum
Beispiel in der Sowjetunion so lange hat
glauben wollen
wir haben ja noch in den 50er 60er
Jahren die Theorie vertreten alles ist
Umwelt also du kommst quasi als die
berühmte tabula rasa genau das ist mein
Gedanke Papier genau das ist ein Gedanke
aus England aus dem 17 Jahrhundert also
John Lock der große Podcast auch schon
häufiger die Rede mal der hat gesagt man
kommt quasi als weißes Blatt Papier auf
die Welt und alles ist eine Frage von
Erziehung und Einfluss und das gleiche
hat auch Jeremy Bentheim geglaubt also
sehr populär in der englischen
Philosophie und dann ein Freund von
Jeremy Bentham ist dann hingegangen John
Mill und hat dann sein Kind so erzogen
ihm gesagt hat okay wenn es überhaupt
keine Frage von vor Strukturierung und
so weiter ist dann werde ich den jetzt
mal mit lateinischer Grammatik auf dem
dritten Lebensjahr aktivieren ja und
jetzt beweise ich mal dass man einen
sauer erzeugen kann nur durch
umwelteinflussen weil das Kind ist
wahrscheinlich nicht schlauer als ich
also wahrscheinlich recht intelligent
aber ist jetzt nicht viel da und ich
mache jetzt ein Genie aus dem kannst
hier da es wurde der bedeutendste
englische Philosoph des 19 Jahrhunderts
John Stewart will das zeigt also wenn
man ein Kind so dermaßen überzüchten und
fördern und mästen kann ja das nach
allen Regeln der Kunst macht dann kann
das tatsächlich Erfolg haben
Haken an der Geschichte John Stuart Mill
war ein Leben lang ein sehr
unglücklicher Mensch
der ganz viele andere Dinge natürlich
nicht gelernt hat hatte nicht mehr
Gleichaltrigen gespielt ne da war nicht
er war auch gar nicht brauchbar für die
weil er ja ein völlig anderen geistigen
Welten lebte musste das alles dann
später beim zweiten Bildungsweg
nachholen ja also wie wie verhält man
sich gegenüber Frauen also das nicht von
der Pike auf gelernt ja sondern ein
völlig viel gezüchtet gewesen ist und
das Beispiel zeigt natürlich man kann
über Umwelt sehr sehr viel machen aber
das heißt im Umkehrschluss nicht man
kann über alles das machen das nannte
sich damals
assoziationspsychologie das heißt also
dass alles was wir mental aufbauen eine
Frage der Verarbeitung von
umwelteinflussen ist
es gibt ja dieses andere berühmte
Experiment von dem ich gelesen habe dass
du nimmst sozusagen eine ganze Reihe von
offensichtlich sehr intelligenten
Kindern
hochbegabte du du
machst es genauso wie das was du eben
gerade beschrieben hast ja du stoppst
alles in die rein was irgendwie geht und
am Ende kommt raus die beiden Kinder die
eine Nobelpreis kriegen das war glaube
ich ein ganz berühmtes Harvard
Experiment sind genau die die bei diesem
Test bei der Vorauswahl durchgefallen
sind die waren gar nicht in der engeren
Gruppe intelligenten drin also ich
glaube dass das alles mögliche ich habe
dieser Tage eine Definition gelesen die
sagt es ist sowohl als auch also Genetik
als auch Umwelteinflüsse die Art und
Weise wie du aufwächst bestimmen am Ende
deine Intelligenz und am Anfang starten
wir alle sozusagen mehr oder weniger
gleich das Spielen aber diese
Umwelteinflüsse eine ganz signifikante
große Rolle und im Laufe des Lebens
wird aber sozusagen das Potenzial deiner
Gene deine das was du einfach wirklich
im Kopf hast wird dann immer wichtiger
das schien mir irgendwie sehr plausibel
das also weil man das sieht man ja auch
ne also die Frage die intelligent man es
hängt ja von so vielen Dingen zusammen
die noch gar nicht formal bestimmen kann
zum Beispiel ist das einst ist wichtig
mit was fütterst du dein Gehirn und zwar
nicht nur füttern andere dein Gehirn
sondern du selber und das ist wieder
abhängig von deiner Motivation genau
wenn du ein wenn du ein unglaublichen
Ehrgeiz hast und du lernst und du du du
rufst dich in die Dinge rein ja und es
bauen sich innere Welten auf und so
weiter das Schuld und trainiert
natürlich ganz genau ja und wenn du auf
der anderen Seite kannst gibt es auch
himmelreichen Beispiele von Menschen die
eigentlich alles Zuflucht und alles
leicht fällt die aber keinen großen
Ehrgeiz haben
so die sind ja eigentlich mal
intelligenter gewesen als die anderen ja
aber man kann sich im Laufe seines
Lebens nicht auf seiner Intelligenz
ausruhen also wenn das da oben nicht
richtig benutzt wird dann rostet das
auch in gewisser Hinsicht ne das weiß
jeder nicht das beginnt nicht erst im
Alter das beginnt ja schon relativ früh
und insofern gibt es auch einen Anteil
dass du bis zu einem gewissen gerade
auch gerade eigenen Intelligenz bist
natürlich nicht vollständig ne aber es
spielt natürlich mit rein
wobei wobei ich mich immer frage ich
treffe auf Leute die wirklich
unvorstellbar klug sind wenn man genau
hinguckt
dann habe ich so im Laufe meines Lebens
zu beobachtest sind häufig Leute die
einen gigantisch gutes Gedächtnis haben
also und ich frage mich dann immer ist
das die klassische Definition von
Intelligenz oder sind das einfach nur
Menschen mit einem irrguten Gedächtnis
gibt leute Leute
die können Telefonbücher auswendig
lernen und sich das auch ewig merken
kein intelligenter Mensch würde
Telefonbücher auswendig lernen
Intelligenz nicht intelligent umgehen
[Gelächter]
und beide Ebenen spielen eine Rolle ja
also einmal die das das wahnsinnig
schneller und leichte lernen können das
ist so das was wir in der Schule
Intelligenz sind und das zweite ist ein
möglichst intelligenten Umgang mit
dieser Intelligenz zu fliegen und das
ist etwas ganz anderes ist richtig
intelligent ist mal wenn beides kann
gibt ja auch in in sang in jüngster Zeit
häufig zu lesen weil es natürlich so
eine welche Schlagzeile ist wie werden
immer dümmer ja wir werden immer blöder
aber wir müssen uns nicht mehr
anstrengen und das Böse Internet und so
weiter und dann gibt es noch Wikipedia
und alles kann man sofort nachschlagen
und die Jugend von heute und so und dann
trinken sie alle noch Hafermilch und so
und dann werden sie alle einfach nichts
zwangsläufig schlauer ich habe das immer
schon für eine sehr starke these
gehalten weil ich immer merke wenn man
mit den jungen Menschen so redet sind
häufig sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr schlaue
junge Leute und ich habe eine sehr
interessante Theorie eines für einen
intelligenzforschers gelesen Jakob
pitschnik der sagt das völliger Quatsch
das viel zu einfach gedacht wir werden
nicht dümmer wir passen uns nur an ja
natürlich und deswegen ist es so eine
scheinbare Trendumkehr ja also im Laufe
der Jahrhunderte wurden die IQs immer
höher immer höher immer höher und jetzt
geht's scheinbar bergab
über Intelligenztest reden weil man kann
natürlich ganz viele Formen zum Beispiel
den intelligenten Umgang mit Intelligenz
in diesen Tests gar nicht messen und das
andere ist mit der Anpassung das stimmt
jede Generation unterliegt einem anderen
Selektionsdruck Ebene also in der
Evolution entwickelt sich der Mensch und
auch seine Intelligenz unter einem
gewissen Selektionsdruck das heißt wir
passen uns unsere Umwelt an und in dem
gleichen Maße wie die Umwelt sich
verändert verändert sich natürlich auch
unsere kognitive Fähigkeit es gibt eine
Kulturen für die was das wichtigste
auswendig zu lernen zum Beispiel weil es
keine Bücher gab also war das natürlich
für für Klugheit und Weisheit das
allerwichtigste dass man sich möglichst
alles merken konnte und das Ewigkeiten
konnte aber das ist erstmal Gedächtnis
ne da war das Gedächtnis irrsinnig
wichtig so so und heute ist es um normal
ist in der Umwelt zu Recht zu kommen das
Gedächtnis in vielen Bereichen deutlich
unwichtiger geworden so dass die Kinder
sich immer fragen in der Schule wieso
muss ich das auswendig lernen hat ja
nachgucken
jetzt kein Plädoyer dafür dass man nicht
auswendig lernen soll weil ich glaube
die Fähigkeit zu besitzen die kann so
als allgemeines Tool eine ganze Menge
bringen ich würde das nicht einfach so
vernachlässigen weil ich sage das
brauchst du nicht mehr so mal eben im
Alltag aber man darf gerne darüber
nachdenken ob das die Seiten im
Erdkundebuch sein müssen so wie bei uns
in der Schule oder ob es vielleicht ganz
andere Dinge sind die man auswendig
lernen müsste vielleicht auch Dinge die
eine gewisse ästhetische Faszination
haben ich finde das nach wie vor nicht
unsinnig heute Gedichte auswendig zu
lernen wir haben da schon mal drüber
gesprochen und wenn ich nachts durch den
Wald gehe und Robert frostgedichte mir
vorher sage und so weiter dann hilft mir
das jedenfalls weiter so und das mögen
für andere Leute andere Dinge sein das
macht mich nicht ja ja durch den Wald
und rezitiert
ja ja genau ich erinnere mich dunkel was
war die schönste Zeile ja das war das
das Waldes dunkel sieht mich ja doch
muss ich zum versprechen stehen und
Meilen gegen bevor ich schlafen kann
du hast ja so ganz viele nonsensreime
drauf ne und die die belastenden
Gedächtnis ja auch ne ja gut also ich
hatte immer schon genauso ein Hang zu
Unsinns Poeten wie zu anderen Poeten
also ich halte Wilhelm Busch nach wie
vor für gigantisch unterschätzt völlig
ja oder Ulrich rosski Ulrich Roski war
ja sozusagen der wieder im Busch der
70er Jahre Teil kennt also in unserer
Hörerschaft keiner mehr also wenn man
böse ist nannte man solche Leute
blödelbahn ja ja genau aber es geht das
was Karl Dall mal war richtig was kalt
war
sprachlich ein bisschen variabler als
kalt
und so eine ganze Reihe von Leuten naja
das war so Prägung meiner Sozialisation
ehrlich und ich muss wirklich sagen also
ein Sinn für Poesie kann man auch dement
nehmen
ja wunderbare alltagsproet die schönste
Zeile Reinhard Mey für dich
jetzt auf Kommando die allerschönste
Zeile daraus zu filtern nicht jetzt aber
nicht jetzt über den Wolken nee über den
Wolken ist ein Schlager also ja mag ich
ja sogar die Version von Dieter Thomas
Kuhn lieber da gibt's doch so eine
mexikanische ich weiß nicht mal sehr
sehr unglücklich darüber
die einzige Möglichkeit dieses Lied
heute noch zu hören lass mich überlegen
in Verbindung mit Alkohol in Verbindung
mit Alkohol das wird sehr gerne im
Karneval gespielt natürlich ja das
stimmt also wenn Alkohol im Spiel ist
ist das Lied richtig gut ich habe
neulich auch Erich Kästner ne der war ja
auch so so gewitzt immer ich habe noch
so einen schönen zweiter davon Erich
Kästner gewesen die Liebe ist ein
zeitvertreibt man nimmt dazu den
Unterleib hmm das ist hübsch ja so
einfach kommt direkt aus der krakenwelt
genau wie Enden wieder wie Enden wieder
beim Kraken absolut Richard noch ganz
kurz Schwarm Intelligenz gibt es also
Fische und Menschen sind sichern dieser
Hinsicht sehr ähnlich ne also und und
Fische sind glaube ich in Schwab
deutlich intelligenter als Menschen im
Schwarm weil relativ ähnliche Muster ja
also ich habe mir ja auch damit mal
beschäftigt in meinem Buch über Moral
wollte ich wissen warum wir in der Moral
immer so leicht andere imitieren also
warum wir das was die anderen machen
eigentlich immer für das moralisch gut
erhalten warum wir uns von
Mehrheitsmeinungen abhängig machen ja
warum wir denken wenn die meisten das so
sehen und so weiter dann wird
wahrscheinlich richtig genau und da habe
ich einen ganz spannenden und auch
unglaublichen netten Menschen
kennengelernt Jens Krause und Jens
Krause ich weiß nicht ob er das heute
noch macht forschte damals ermügelt sie
in Berlin und leitete dort ein Institut
bleibt nichts Institut oder so was für
Gewässer Ökologie ich war im Verhalten
genau Forschungsgruppe
einer der führenden Männer zum Thema
Schwarm Verhalten oder führende Forscher
in den zum Thema Schwarm verhalten
und der versuchte er eben herauszufinden
wie ist das ne woher weiß der Schwarm wo
er hingeht und man hat den Rechtsstreit
und wann hat der links 3 und mit all
diesen Erkenntnissen hat er dann so
spannende Sachen gemacht wie beim
Stadionbau beraten oder Geheimdienst und
polizeiberaten
ich erinnere mich an einen experiment
was er mir vorgeführt hat also auf dem
Video gezeigt hat du hast ganz hunderte
von Leuten in irgendeinem
und als Testpersonen hunderte und die
haben eine Aufgabe sie müssen einfach
nur gehen und es gibt eine zweite
Aufgabe und die besteht darin du darfst
aber nie mehr als ein Meter an jemand
anders rankommen
und am Anfang ist das natürlich ein
riesiges Kuddelmuddel und plötzlich
sortiert sich das Bild und es gibt einen
großen Kreis der irgendwie rechts
rumgeht alle gehen irgendwann ja wie in
so einem Wirbel immer im Kreis und
soweit ich mich erinnere ein kleiner
Kreis ihnen drin der andersrum geht das
heißt also es schält sich sozusagen das
große mehrheitsverhalten heraus und so
ein kleines minderheitsverhalten was in
die andere Richtung geht das sind aber
nur ganz weniger und das passiert
automatisiert weil keiner der einzelnen
die an dem Prozess dabei sind mit
Absicht sich jetzt sagt ich will jetzt
einen Kreis gehen oder sowas ja solche
Sachen sind wahnsinnig spannend das
heißt also wie etwas das in uns ist dass
uns nicht bewusst ist dazu treibt
bestimmte Verhaltensmuster zu übernehmen
und etwas wahrzunehmen was wir gar nicht
bewusst wahrnehmen und so in diesen
Schwarm Sog hinein zu geraten sind ganz
toll also wir versuchen Muster zu
erkennen ich versuchen und wir versuchen
nie wir versuchen dabei ein Muster ohne
es zu erkennen wir wollen einfach nur
dabei sein und zack bilden wir ein
Muster interessant das heißt kognitiv
spielt sich da gar nichts ab also wir
brauchen hier keine Intelligenz für das
ist irgend so so was was was außerhalb
unserer ist quasi was was da passiert
sehr spannend interessant ja super
richard hat Spaß gemacht mit dir mal ein
bisschen über Intelligenz nachzudenken
wünsch dir einen schönen Tag und bis
nächste Woche herrlich danke also bis
nächste Woche ja mach's gut tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und
Popstars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]